f of X is equal to 2x squared plus 15 X
minus 8 G of X is equal to x squared
plus 10 X plus 16 find F over G of X or
you could interpret this as f divided by
G of X and so based on the way I just
said it you kind of have a sense of what
this means F over G or F divided by G of
X by definition this is just another way
to write f of X divided by G of X you
could view this as a function a function
of X that's defined by the by dividing f
of X by G of X by creating a rational
expression where f of X is in the
numerator and G of X is in the
denominator and so this is going to be
equal to f of X we have right up here is
2x squared - x squared + 15 X - 8 and G
of X I will do in blue is right over
here G of X so this is all going to be
over G of X which is x squared plus 10x
x squared plus 10 X plus 16 and you
could leave it this way or you could
actually try to simplify this a little
bit and the easiest way to simplify this
would see if we can factor the numerator
and the denominator expressions into
maybe simpler expressions and maybe some
of them might be on maybe both the
numerator denominator is divisible by
the same expression so let's try to
factor each of them so first let's try
the numerator and I'll actually do it up
here so let's do it actually I'll do it
down here so if I'm looking at 2 x
squared + 15 X - 8 we have a quadratic
expression where the coefficient the
coefficient is not 1 and so one
technique to factor this is to factor by
grouping you could also use the
quadratic formula and when you factor by
grouping you're going to split up this
term this 15 X and you're going to split
it up into two you're going to split it
up into two terms where the coefficients
are if I were to take the if I were to
take the product of those coefficients
they're going to be equal to the product
of the first of the last terms and we
prove that in other videos so
essentially we want to think of two
numbers that add up to 15
but whose product is equal to negative
16 and this is just a technique of
factoring by grouping it's really just
in an attempt to simplify this right
over here so what two numbers that if I
take their product I get negative 16 but
if I add them I get 15 well if I take
their product and get a negative number
that means they have to have a different
sign and so that means one of them is
going to be positive one of the big
ativy one's going to be larger than
fifteen and one of them is going to be
smaller than fifteen and the most
obvious one there might be 16 positive
16 and negative one if I multiply these
two things I definitely get negative 16
if I add these two things I definitely
get I definitely get 15 so we could what
we can do is we can split this we can
rewrite this expression as 2x squared
plus 2x squared plus 16 16x minus X
minus X minus 8 all I did here is I took
this middle term I took this middle term
and using this technique right over here
I split it into 16x minus X which is
clearly still just 15 X now what's
useful about this and this is why we
call it factoring by grouping is we can
see are there any common factors in
these first two terms right over here
well both 2x squared + 16 X they are
both divisible by 2 X so you can factor
out a 2x of these first two terms so
this is the same thing as 2x times X
plus X plus 8 all right 16 divided by 2
is 8
X divided by X is 1 so this is 2x times
X plus 8 and then these second two terms
right over here and this is the whole
basis of factoring by grouping we can
factor out a negative 1 so this is equal
to negative 1 times X plus 8 and what's
neat here is now we have two terms both
of them have an X plus 8 in them so we
can factor out an X plus 8 so if we
factor out an X plus 8 if we factor out
an X plus 8 we get we're left with 2x
we're left with 2x minus 1 2x minus 1
I'll put parentheses around at times the
factored out X plus 8 so
we've simplified the numerator the
numerator can be rewritten and you could
have gotten here using the quadratic
formula as well the numerator is 2x
minus 1 times X plus 8 and now let's see
if we can factor the denominator and
this one's more straightforward the
coefficient here is 1 so we just have to
think of two numbers that when I
multiply them I get 16 and when I add
them I get 10 and the obvious one is 8
and 2 positive 8 and 2 and positive 2 so
we can write this as X plus 2 times X
plus X plus 8 and now we can simplify it
we can divide the numerator and the
denominator by X plus 8 assuming
assuming that X does not equal negative
8 because this function right over here
that's defined by F divided by G it is
not defined when G of X is equal to zero
because then you have something divided
by zero when what and the only times
that G of X is equal to zero is when X
is equal to negative 2 or X is equal to
negative 8 so if we divide the numerator
in the denominator by X plus 8 to
simplify it in order to not change the
function definition we have to still put
the constraint that X cannot be equal to
negative 8 that the original function in
order to not change it because if I just
cancel these two things out the new
function with these cancel would be
defined when X is equal to negative 8
but we want to simplify thing to be the
same exact function and this exact
function is not defined when X is equal
to negative 8 so now we can write F over
G of X which is really just f of X
divided by G of X is equal to 2x minus 1
over X plus 2 if you have to put the
condition there that X cannot be equal
to negative 8 if you lost this condition
then it won't be the exact same function
as this because this is not defined when
X is equal to negative 8